ahora vamos a instalar nuestro
interruptor de encendido y apagado y el
interruptor que controlará los leds así
que vamos a poner dos gotas de silicon
caliente de la mitad de tamaño de una
moneda de cinco pesos abajo en la parte
posterior del robot y recuerden deben
estar seguros de que el silicón caliente
no interfiera con el deslizamiento del
interruptor o con los contactos de la
parte posterior ya que si presionas este
interruptor y tiene pegamento entonces
no funcionará correctamente así que
mejor asegúrate de que no pongan
pegamento en el interruptor y una vez
que ya está en su lugar el silicón
caliente en realidad seca muy rápido y
mucho más en una superficie metálica
porque esta le ayuda a disipar el calor
del pegamento así que una vez que estos
estén en su lugar podemos empezar a
conectar nuestros motores los que se
encenderán y se apagarán con el
interruptor el primer cable que vamos a
conectar va a ser para conectar los dos
motores juntos esto
darán a completar el circuito y lo que
haremos eso tenemos un cable que es más
o menos de largo adecuado es decir cerca
de tres pulgadas de largo y pelaremos
tres cuartos de pulgada de un lado y
bueno la razón por la cual estoy pelando
tanto aislante es porque después
necesitaríamos conectar otro cable a
este cable que tenemos aquí del otro
lado sólo quitaremos cerca de un cuarto
de pulgada así que este es el otro lado
que tiene un poco más de un cuarto no sé
tal vez tres octavos de pulgada y de
nuevo vamos a enlazarlo a través del
contacto de latón y queremos estar
seguros de que toca el latón o al menos
que lo toca lo mejor posible para que
esté firmemente conduciendo la
electricidad tal vez esto tenga un poco
de maña y seguramente van a pasar un
poco de tiempo con todo esto pero
funcionará y lo que usualmente hago es
pasar el cable a través del bucle y
después pasar el cable al otro lado y
conectar de nuevo el lado más largo del
en el motor y el cable que tenemos extra
lo vamos a necesitar para hacer otra
conexión así que lo voy a dejar así pero
voy a enroscar el cable alrededor del
contacto de latón no lo olvides
recuerda intentar tener tanto cable en
contacto con el latón como sea posible y
para eso voy a tomar estas pinzas de
punta que me van a ayudar vamos a
apretarlo contra el cable en los motores
y una cosa que diré es que estos
contactos de latón son muy pequeños y
delgados y pueden romperse fácilmente
así que deben ser cuidadosos en como
prensan el cable sobre el contacto del
latón justo allí bien ahora hemos tomado
un pedazo de cable amarillo cerca de 2
pulgadas de largo
hemos pelado los extremos y puesto un
bucle que vamos a prensar en el extremo
sobre nuestro interruptor no es tan
fácil de armar el robot de esta manera
porque no estamos usando
soldadura claramente la soldadura es
conductiva y básicamente actúa como un
pegamento y además conduce electricidad
pero el pegamento que estamos usando en
este caso el silicón caliente no conduce
electricidad así que es muy importante
que nuestras conexiones de cables queden
bastante firmes es por eso que puede que
necesites ajustar varias veces para
tener el cable prensado de tal manera
que sostenga con fuerza a la conexión
con el interruptor el mío por ejemplo se
ha soldado así que seguir adelante y
ponerlo de nuevo otra vez impreso y
consigo sostener firmemente en su lugar
al cable con las pinzas de punta
inclusive pueden doblar las terminales
hacia arriba para darle un poco más de
de algo para agarrarse
bien ahora voy a pasar el otro lado del
cable amarillo a la parte expuesta del
cable verde que acabamos de conectar a
los motores así que lo pondré allí y voy
a trenzar los justo como hicimos cuando
conectamos no sé los leds o cuando
unimos el cable negativo con nuestros
interruptores y de nuevo queremos
asegurarnos de trenzar lo varias veces
así vamos a tener una buena conexión
sólida
ojo queremos asegurarnos que el cable
amarillo no toca la otra terminal en el
interruptor porque de lo contrario
siempre estará encendido y no seremos
capaces de encender y apagar el robot
ahora que ya hemos probado nuestros
motores podemos seguir adelante y
colocar el silicón caliente sobre las
conexiones de los cables asegurándonos
de que están todas conectadas y ya hemos
probado nuestros cables azules así que
vamos a seguir adelante y colocar
silicón caliente sobre esas conexiones y
eso ayudará a sostener el cable en su
lugar y también ayudará a aislarlo bien
ahora lo que necesitamos hacer es
conectar el otro cable aquel que
acabamos de conectar al otro cable
amarillo a nuestro interruptor así que
la manera en la que el interruptor
funciona es bueno espera en realidad
este es un interruptor de tres
conexiones y es un interruptor de un
polo y dos posiciones
es un interruptor deslizable de un polo
y dos posiciones que es lo contrario a
un interruptor de un polo y dos
posiciones de palanca el cual tenemos al
frente del robot así que solo
necesitamos dos de estas conexiones y no
vamos a necesitar tres de ellas y
realmente no importa ustedes pueden
escoger dos conexiones en un lado o dos
en el otro pero eso sí deben escoger dos
que estén una al lado de la otra con la
finalidad de que el interruptor funcione
así que como ya no necesitaremos esta
conexión de aquí entonces doblaremos
fuera del camino esta clavija esta
clavija no será útil porque todo lo que
queremos hacer es abrir y cerrar el
circuito no queremos cambiar entre dos
circuitos diferentes lo siguiente que
haremos es tomar el resto de nuestro
cable amarillo y vamos a apelar de nuevo
cerca de tres octavos de pulgada o un
cuarto de pulgada de aislante y una vez
que tenemos eso vamos a crear un bucle y
vamos a unir
en bucle a la terminal expuesta que está
en nuestro interruptor la cual es la
terminal que está en medio del
interruptor es decir si vemos desde
arriba y vemos la terminal del lado
izquierdo entonces ahí es donde vamos a
conectar el cable
ya tenemos el cable cortado y pelado y
con un bucle en él y estamos pensándolo
a esta terminal central y vamos a
apretarlo fuertemente contra la terminal
central con nuestras piezas de punta
para probar la conexión vamos a poner
ese cable de vuelta a las baterías y de
hecho pueden escuchar el motor corriendo
ahora seguiremos adelante y vamos a
colocar el silicón caliente y lo vamos a
colocar ahora que ya sabemos que
funciona de nuevo básicamente lo que el
interruptor está haciendo es permitirnos
convertir nuestras baterías que están
conectadas en serie lo que duplica el
voltaje a paralelo y eso nos permite
duplicar la capacidad y correr los
motores a una menor velocidad y una vez
que el silicón caliente ha tomado el
color lechoso y se ha enfriado entonces
vamos a conectar el cable a la batería
en la parte posterior el pegamento está
frío así que seguir adelante y votar en
la batería fuera del soporte hay un
pequeño agujero allí donde podemos
adorar el cable y lo primero que
necesitamos hacer es quitar la batería
así podemos introducir el cable y
doblarlo hacia arriba y mientras el
cable esté conectado contra el lado del
soporte y contra el pequeño remache
a tener una buena conexión eléctrica
porque ese resorte que está dentro del
soporte de las baterías va a empujar las
baterías contra el remache y contra
nuestro cable y con esto vamos a
asegurar de que es una buena conexión
sólida y una vez que coloquemos la
batería de vuelta vamos a probarlo para
asegurar que todo esté funcionando
pongan solo un poco de cinta en los
motores para asegurar que podamos verlos
girar
así que pueden activar los motores con
el interruptor de un polo y dos
posiciones o dos interruptores de
palanca o pueden mantenerlos activados
permanentemente con el interruptor
deslizable así que cuando presionan los
interruptores de palanca provocan que
los motores retrocedan y eso significa
que nuestro robot será capaz de
retroceder